ضبر ياقوت رئيس ماسكوي صباح الخير من
موسكو نادين وسهام وعام مليء بالخير عليكم
ان شاء الله نحن في مكان غير اعتيادي تروي
بعض الروايات بان هذا المنزل عاشوا مقربون
من القياسره طبعا ضيفي اليوم ليس له
ارتباط بسلاله القياسره لكنه قيصر بما
تحكي بما تحمل الكلمه من معنا يلقب بامير
الشرق اغانيه واعماله الفنيه طبعا صعدت
الى درجه التوب وشغلت مراكز متقدمه في
العالم على مدى عشرات السنوات طبعا في
روسيا لم يتمكن حتى هذه اللحظه اي شخص او
اي مغني او اي حدا يعمل في المجال الفني
بتحطيم رقمه القياسي وهو البقاء لاكثر من
سنه
اكثر شخص متابعه في عالم الفن والغناء في
القنوات الاذاعيه
اطل عليكم كثيرا دعونا نتعرف على من تسميه
وتلقبه حسناوات موسكو بالرجل الجميل صباح
الخير اكرام صباح النور هلا هلا هلا يا
غالي
ابرام
الشمس بمسكو هلا شرقي لكن حابين نبلش
ونسمع منك قدود حلبيه كمفاجاه من داخل
موسكو بيغني يعني بغني لك هلا بس اجمالا
بحلب بيغنوه
العصر حتى يعني بنص الليل
امان امان امان امان امان امان امان امان
[موسيقى]
يا ويلي
امان امان امان امان
[موسيقى]
امان امان امان
امان
يا ربي
كفاك شجار من تاه ملوع ولا عالم بحالي شجر
[موسيقى]
اويلي
ظلم الاحبه بعد المهما بحكمه شجار راضي
راضي ولو صرت عند اهل العشق عبره
عالج جروحي
رحله مكوكيه في العالم
الكويت ومصر العراق
ارمينيا قبرص روسيا والان في امريكا تعيش
الان بين امريكا
اكيد اكيد 16 سنه بلش تغني اول اول بدايه
المشوار يعني كان صعب كثير لحد الان صعب
ما في شيء هايم بهالدنيا
فحولت من بلد
منور كيف عايش نفس القصه
دخلت صار عندي اسم بيروسيا
رهيب
الناس هنا ما بيحترموا الانسان اذا انت
مالك كبير
عرفت كيف
عم يحكي معي
يسعد صباحكم عبد الجواد وافرام انت بلشت
حديثك بالروسي تسلم علينا فبما انه بما
انه افران ارمله راح نحكي معه ارمله ونسال
السؤال يجاوبنا ويغني لنا كمان راح احكي
مع افرام فرايف
ترجمه
مترجم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اغنيه
خلص اوكي
[موسيقى]
ههه حابين نسمع منك شيء كخليط بين الروسي
والعربي من اللي بتقدموا على المسارح
بدنا الكلام
المقطع العربي الي زمان سجلته مصر الاغنيه
بس ضربته هون ضربه قويه يعني
ما اعرفش انا ليه
[موسيقى]
اه ونسوني جبتها
سبت لها دموع وجراح ويا ريتني اعيش بعد
مرتاح لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا
لا لا لا لا لا لا الاغنيه
ولكن وقت ما انتهى للاسف
طيب افرام لو سمحت انا بعرف انه في عندك
حفلات امام العديد من الرؤساء لكن مين
الاسماء اللامعه اللي اشتغلت مع ان كانت
بروسيا او اشتغلت معها بالعالم العربي حتى
نعرف القيم وكلمات والحال مين شغلات
كريستيانو
مثلا
ببلاد العربيه
طيب افرع بنتمنى لك كل التوفيق
وحفلاتك القادمه ان شاء الله وداوما الا
لقاءات كمان دور على صباح العربيه نادين
وسهام اكرام